we were trying to look after people but
we were also trying to ask and we did
ask questions repeatedly continuously
and were repeatedly told there was
nothing happening and I also said that
as we see it today our understanding and
our information so far is that we could
not have done this differently but if
the Casey does say and recommend that in
future we should do any aspects
differently we will listen we will learn
and we will act but today and there were
no nobody
nobody would be turning a blind eye to
something it's not a blind eye I mean
nobody here or on the management board
would ever turn a blind eye to something
as serious as this